winter is coming and the bodies are
starting to pile up episode 5 kissed by
fire it's not quite as intensive as last
episode was but things are still moving
forward they're maintaining momentum and
that's good enough for me we get a lot
of great stuff here a lot of what's
going on in King's Landing right now
really has me intrigued in terms of
people forming new alliances and the new
players who are now part of that scene
there because it really does feel like
the Tourelles are really throwing a
wrench into the Lannisters playing it's
nice to see them just sort of little
push and pull who's gonna out manipulate
the other one Tywin Lannister he feels
the closest to somebody who's gotten the
most control over everything going on
he's not in complete control button that
guy's got his [ __ ] together and getting
to know him better in terms of how he
drives with his kids cuz he's got a
great scene with seriously interior I'm
just enjoying his time on screen we
learned a bit more about Stannis
Baratheon in this one now this guy the
more I learned about him the less I like
him which is interesting cuz he when he
first showed up he was like a potential
new hero here and then the more I get to
know him no no no Daenerys I'm still
enjoying her she's got like a quick
moment here we get a flash of her
naivety naivete nivin but it's gone an
instant so it's fine Jaime Lannister has
a fantastic monologue in this and we're
really getting a lot of depth to this
kind of just sort of flippant whatever
character that he was in the first
couple seasons now I was like whoa
although I want to say I see a pretty
clear line of what's what they're gonna
do with him and Brienne of Tarth I'm
like I'm not sure I want to see a go
there but in the meantime fantastic now
there are a couple of things that happen
in this episode that kind of bugged me
one is a little major the other one I
know is more of a nitpick the bigger one
is we've got a sex scene in this episode
and it's not the prom that I had last
time where it's like it's gratuitous I
get where it's coming from it is based
in character but I'm still annoyed that
it happened because i feel like it
reduces the female character in the
pairing
I found her much more interesting when
it was sort of like unspoken under the
surface and now she's just flat-out take
me I'm like and now you're boring it was
just such an obvious place to go in and
went there just so here it is now
whatever now the thing that knows a
little bit more pit nitpicking this is
about the Brotherhood and they're kind
of cool i like them as a concept sort of
group of characters who aren't really
serving anybody clearly but i kind of
don't like the fact that they're
worshipping the Lord of Light who is the
same one that the woman in red serves I
really kind of wish that they were
worshiping another deity because I I
like the idea of these different
theologies facing off because you'd like
on the iron Isles when they talk about
the drowned God and/or the Starks talk
about the the old gods and you know it's
interesting stuff but now we've got
multiple people saying they're
worshipping the Lord of Light and I'm
like wow does that mean i can assume you
guys are all going to meet up because
you're serving the same deity and the
other thing is there's events that
happen in this that are really starting
to imply that the Lord of Light is an
actual being with that is granting them
actual powers and I'm hoping that's not
the case I'm not saying that's
definitively where they're going but I
could see it going there and I really
hope it doesn't because what I love
about the show is it's about people the
minute you really establish that there
is some sort of deity out there and now
it's not about people anymore but I'm
kind of hoping the Lord of Light
specifically as a power source gets
undermined at some point because seems
like he's just getting built up more and
more and I really don't want them to be
again minor issues this is still all
great stuff i feel like the show's
really in its try right now it's pushing
forward with great momentum and i can't
wait to see the next one so i mentioned
the sexual pairing that annoyed me when
it happened has there ever been in a
show or a movie that sort of will they
won't they pairing that you were hoping
oh god don't let them and they did that
ever happen do you leave a comment let's
talk about it and until next time this
council is adjourned
you